in mid-september 1888 a penniless
Dutchman who would in a few months be
committed to an asylum and be dead
within two years sat down in the Eastern
corner of the plaster Forum in Al and
set to work on one of the most
astonishing and beloved paintings ever
made
Cafe Terrace at night juxtaposes are
snug nighttime rituals under our defiant
man-made lamps with the ultimate
Mysteries and Sublimity of the cosmos
and yet as we know Vincent van Gogh
found no buyers for his Masterpiece no
Museum came begging no Gallery gave a
damn his work appeared wholly worthless
to his entire era he could barely afford
lunch or a new pair of shoes the local
children mocked him rarely has a more
despised or marginal figure walked the
Earth
the story is so familiar that we are apt
to lose sight of its ongoing relevance
and Universal import
people miss things on a very large scale
they did so then and by implication they
must continue to do so now
the reasons are not very complicated and
don't belong to any sort of conspiracy
essentially humans are heard animals
they show immense loyalty to group think
and Resolute opposition to Independent
analysis they follow what is fashionable
they are appalled where they are told to
be appalled and admiring where they are
told to admire they will bow to Van Gogh
when instructed to and stamp on Van Gogh
when no one tells them not to without
making any claims for our genius we
should take inspiration
if there are ways in which we are
presently neglected and criticized we
should be wholly unsurprised and more
importantly unfrightened
this is the way things have always and
will always be
an alternative to hating and undermining
ourselves is to be at points a lot more
acerbic about the sort of people we live
among
and a lot more confident in our own path